comment ça va bien tout le monde sait
squeeze aujourd'hui le remix nul on se
retrouve sur grenoble shon
c'est une deuxième vidéo sur ce jeu les
sorties sur steam depuis la dernière
fois il ya un peu de nouveaux contenus
ces partis une passion c'est d'attirer
la police c'est parti ça vous avez
manqué moi oui prometteuse et de la
vidéo voilà c'est un honneur voilà c'est
la main sur le coeur est ce que je peut
rayer la voiture au nom par contre lui
peut rayer ma moto voyez j'ai une barre
de menu en haut à gauche et qu'on n'y a
plus de vie bah je perds et je dois
recommencer du niveau 3 voilà il fait
quoi le fil devant élever l'équipe de
drogue au moins aux médias les voies
légales ya des agents police ici un oh
oh oui je me le fais je vous ai dit je
le fais à a donc lâché que deux étoiles
il m'en faut cinq ans mais ma mais
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour un 5
étoiles quoi j'ai juste eu et 18 agents
de police casser une voiture mais ouais
ce qui se passe à cause de moi mais j'ai
passat étoiles dans attend le make up
l'ex idole mais un coup en l'air où tu
vas te calmer et patois acacus c'était
reste en dehors de ça à temps mais n'ont
aucun jeu c'est aussi dur d'attirer la
police qua non non non aux labos les bib
abouba but on fait ça à la pelle à merde
coup j'ai une vieille matraque atteint
mais c'est super dur de conduire retiré
ok ah bah voilà vous avez trois des cinq
stars braves ont dégagé les membres du
gang rival avant la fin du temps imparti
ça marche qu'on va se restaurer de la
vie up vu qu'on avait pas mal d'argent
au wynn court sur les toits mon gars non
mais ça j'aime pas parce que on sait pas
où vous allez regardez moi ça ben oui
mais cette violence mais le mec en l'air
avec une pelle tranquille où il revient
du chant et regarder mama traquer le
troll alors il fait des caisses
as tu connais ça pour fall et h et ben
non ça va plutôt maintenant ça va plutôt
maintenant mesdames et regarde y'a même
des voitures dans la course quoi on les
skiffs que je lui ai mis et je reviens
je fais de rayures merde hein
ok ça marche
mais attends mais c'est moi dans cette
version les voitures et les moteurs sont
carrément dix fois plus fou que dans la
version d'avant comme bonjour ou au tac
des fois j'ai bien de la chance mais ça
c'est le casse voilà on vous disait
souvent de porter un casque quand vous
êtes une moto et un vrai et ça sert à ça
et là ça aussi je vous jure le jeu à
fond
mais je sais comment il faut avait les
tables parages quoi battant mais on l'a
vu on a tous pensé la même chose quoi
comment allons nous en sortir je suis
deuxième quart et manger des 70% des
récompenses bah voilà au jeu revit avec
toute ma vie quand je meurs alors là je
pense à direct c'est génial alors là
ouais ses débuts mackay qui s'appelle je
m'en fous je l'attends sait qu elle
s'appelle au dessus non il a failli nous
tuer mais sa part sur les toits quoi
c'est scandaleux n'est pas trop mal non
on est très très mal
un temps en 1 on a une arme à d'accord
ça m'accroche
non mais faut que celle des accrocs non
mais ce cap a fait tomber [ __ ] arrête
mais normes et mais laissez moi vivre
que je peux m'accrocher au chaud je
perds du genre de spider man en fait on
va juste tire sur toi à toi mais voilà
s'il te plaît tu t'envoles vraiment
autour de toi aussi tu passes et
grappins dans l'immeuble
ballester there is hot et ni fenêtre je
fais comment à ce jeu le jeu les
lyonnais a jeté sur lui et sur lui et
bah tu vas tomber avec moi mon gars tu
vas tomber avec moi il est où ses os a
vu ce qu'est ce qui se passe bien
voyez aucun problème mission perdu votre
nom il est parti en fait ma mission
c'est juste de tout défoncer quoi qu
mais c'est encore m'étais pas qu'il
avait une pelle non l ap ap les papes l
on a pu regarder le hot wave qu'est ce
que vous voulez hausse
on a lu on est carrément violent mais
j'ai réussi la mission en fait on a été
tellement violent que je faisais pour qu
on a gagné c'est magique ce qui s'est
passé mais c'est le caravan comment ça
va il ya des gens à qui va falloir
apprendre les bonnes manières moi je
vous le dis par exemple lui voilà je
n'ai raté au par exemple cette voiture
e o on me l'a volé le cactus me l'a volé
non aux attentes je spoile notre média
coupelles mais vous vous dites vraiment
qui se détendent serait quoi ah non là
c'est le retour de la main à la pelle
non c'est bon c'est parti en héros sur
les toits j'adore oh mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
non mais tu es sont des spiderman on
l'est pas mais on peut pas semblant
d'être un moment puis là-bas au fond au
plus tard ben voilà on ne passe pas
normal on est monsieur bronx et on a
gagné
ah non il reste 1 on a gagné
alors c'est quoi lance grenades puis ça
fait attiré la police on la tient comme
ça donc au bon à tirer la police et
samatan mais là ça suffit pas ce qui se
passe
voiture à la police par exemple merde et
on a un jet pack attendait pardon
excusez moi voilà qu'en d'helmand j'ai
rien compris à ce qui se passe alors
nous je tiens à dire la police qu'on n'a
rien à voir et tout ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est là où tu peux mettre
des petits noms à temps mais là il veut
un rêve là mais c'est scandaleux on
attend mais ils sont en un mois le mec
ses gestes mais surtout regarder et vous
savez ce que j'en réserve comme ça en
moi aux gens comme vous ça offert doit
peut-être pas dû à à batam à ça c'est
très bien pour transporter son voisin ça
j'adore moi j'aime bien cette équipe que
je fais aussi utilisent les seconds
jetpack pour aller jusqu'au point où
j'ai été trop gourmand
bah ouais j'espère que passait par là
puis par la barre là et on va remonter
on va remonter on va remonter avec un
petit coup de jet pack quoi mais c'est
ce qu'on aime il y avait quoi y avait un
lézard au milieu de la route
oh non non j'ai perdu au bout puis ça
fait boum j'ai gagné non il me restait
qu'à moi je me voyais déjà parti à los
angeles pour faire une liste porte sur
rod redemption
on aurait été 3 mais c'est pas grave aux
voitures à les poteaux ma voiture du
doubs je grave
auger gr b ça lui a damé attend mais tu
me remercie pas comme ça
déjà au tumulte rails la touche d'autres
qui ne termine sur les toits et on va
tuer ce mec en l'air ok j'ai tué tous
qui avez autour mais pas l'unique est
une voiture faisait sur les toits mais
pourquoi il ya de la circulation comme
c'est joël au travail tranquillement
dans les toits on va terminer sur cette
belle course à regarder les taxis
tranquillement comme si quelqu'un vous
la taxe depuis un toit se jouer en fout
c'est le premier fois le défoncer c'est
la cible à abattre
j'ai pas ce que j'ai comme arme mais en
tout cas les tiens on a fini deuxième
c'est pas mal je veux que les gens se
dire fin de cette deuxième vidéo sur
leur adoption
j'espère que vous appuyez si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à faire spider man
avec un harpon ça ne marchera pas mais
essayez toujours mais c'est surtout pas
ça fait plus à deux ou trois juges et ça
ça vous a fait plaisir aussi
il est vraiment fun sympa a pas de prise
de tête il des explosions partout des
gens qui volent serment super marrant et
puis on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat au monde
j'ai tenté un truc épique mais bon faut
rajouter une musique par dessus